Wann schämst du dich, Yves?
Wenn ich etwas vergesse, nachlässig oder
egozentrisch bin, andere im Regen stehen lasse.
Ich würde sagen,
ich schäme mich für viele Dinge - zu Recht.
Aber nicht,
wenn ich am FKK-Strand meinen Spass habe.
Du gehst sicher nicht an einen FKK-Strand,
das sagst du nur.
Ich habe das ein-, zweimal gemacht.
Im Ausland.
Hallo zusammen, wir sind zurück
mit der zweiten Staffel "Bleisch & Bossart".
Yves Bossart und ich, Barbara Bleisch,
diskutieren über philosophische Alltagsfragen.
Genau.
In der ersten Staffel habt ihr
fleissig kommentiert und diskutiert
auf YouTube, Facebook und Instagram.
Das hat uns sehr gefreut, denn Philosophie
ist immer ein Gespräch, eine Diskussion.
Wir hoffen, dass ihr uns in dieser Staffel
wieder mit Kommentaren flutet.
Heute geht es ums Thema Scham
und um die Frage, ob Scham etwas Gutes ist.
Barbara, gibt es etwas, worüber du dich schämst,
das dir richtig peinlich ist?
Wir kennen wohl alle die Situation,
wenn einem ein Furz entwischt.
- Das passiert dir?
- Ja, sicher.
Am schlimmsten sind die,
die man nicht hört, die aber stinken.
Dann weiss man nicht,
ob man sich entschuldigen muss. Nicht wahr?
In den acht Jahren Zusammenarbeit
habe ich noch nie etwas gehört oder gerochen.
Okay, da bin ich sehr froh.
Ich finde es auch peinlich, wenn man
bei einem Vortrag oder im Schauspielhaus
gegen den Schlaf kämpft und langsam einnickt.
- Das passiert dir auch?
- Dir nicht?
Ich hatte z.B. Lachanfälle an der Uni.
Ich erinnere mich genau.
Ich habe mein Lachen lange zurückgehalten,
dann kam es zum Kontrollverlust.
- Das ist aber schön.
- Nicht für die, die vorne stehen.
Die wissen nicht, ob man wegen ihnen
oder etwas anderem lacht. Schrecklich.
Aber vieles ist kulturell konnotiert.
Das Thema Schlaf finde ich interessant.
In Japan z.B. sind U-Bahnen eine Art Schlafwagen.
Die Menschen holen während dem Pendeln
Schlaf vor oder nach.
Da schläft man einfach.
In der Schweiz darf man im Zug schlafen,
aber bitte ...
- Nicht sabbern.
- Geräuschlos, nicht schnarchen oder zucken.
Kürzlich zeigte mir ein Freund,
wie man sich im Sitzen im Zug verkeilen muss,
damit es emissionsfrei bleibt.
Z.B. so:
Beine übereinander, den Kiefer einstecken.
Dann fliesst keine Spucke raus.
- So geht der Mund, der Kiefer nicht auf.
- Ja.
Sehr gut. Dann noch ein Buch halten.
So kann ich aber auch nicht schlafen.
Bei all diesen Beispielen
haben wir unseren Körper nicht mehr unter Kontrolle.
Es geht auch um moralische Vergehen.
Man kann hervorheben,
dass Scham oder Schuldgefühle
eine Begleiterscheinung von Freiheit sind.
Die Urszene der Scham waren Adam und Eva.
Sie haben bzw. nehmen sich die Freiheit,
vom Baum der Erkenntnis zu essen.
Indem sie sich die Freiheit nehmen,
eine Norm übertreten, eine Regel brechen,
kommt das Schamgefühl.
D.h., Freiheit und Scham gehen Hand in Hand.
Man möchte im Boden versinken
und unsichtbar sein.
Das ist wichtig, aber im Unsichtbarsein
steckt auch etwas Philosophisches.
Jean-Paul Sartre, der französische Philosoph, sagte,
der Mensch habe deshalb ein Schamgefühl,
weil der Blick der anderen auf ihn fällt.
Scham ist eine Emotion.
Sie ist jedoch nicht angeboren.
Ein Säugling oder ein Kleinkind schämt sich nicht,
das kommt erst mit der Zeit.
Wut und Trauer verspüren schon kleine Kinder,
aber Scham kommt erst mit der Zeit,
wenn man sich bewusst ist,
dass einen andere anschauen,
und man sich anstelle der anderen anschauen kann.
Genau, wenn man eine soziale Norm verletzt,
etwas falsch gemacht hat - auf irgendeine Art.
Manchmal ist das moralisch konnotiert,
manchmal in Bezug auf Sexualität oder Intimität.
Man entblösst sich, gibt einen Aspekt von sich preis,
den man lieber nicht hätte,
oder nicht möchte, dass andere davon wissen.
Wofür schämt man sich heute mehr als früher?
Ich glaube, weniger für Körperliches,
sondern eher
durch den moralisch aufgeladenen Alltag.
Wenn ich mit dem Flugzeug reise ...
Stichwort Flugscham.
Oder ich traue mich nicht, Fleisch zu essen, weil
Vegetarier oder Veganer in der Nähe sein könnten.
Viele moralische Dinge aus dem Alltag
sind für Menschen mit Scham behaftet.
Aber Ulrich Greiners These in "Schamverslust"
besagt,
es gehe oft um ästhetische Regeln in Gruppen.
Wenn du eine Affäre mit deiner Nachbarin hast,
brauchst du dich nicht schämen - im Gegenteil.
Unter Umständen ist es in deiner Gruppe peinlich,
nie einen Seitensprung zu haben.
Es ist viel peinlicher,
wenn die Frisur nicht bis zum Abend sitzt
oder wenn man an einer Party
dasselbe Kleid wie die Freundin trägt.
Aber es gab doch schon früher
soziale Konventionen,
wie man sich anziehen, wie man sprechen soll usw.
Auch den Statusverlust, den man in Kauf nimmt,
wenn man etwas falsch macht, eine Regel verletzt.
Das stimmt, das glaube ich auch.
Ich glaube, den Begriff "Statusscham",
den Greiner verwendet, gab es früher auch schon.
Wenn man sich nicht entsprechend anziehen konnte,
fiel man aus der Klasse.
Das gibt es heute noch,
aber er sagt etwas Interessantes:
In einer pluralistischen Gesellschaft
kann man Peinlichkeit als Seismograf einsetzen.
- Je nachdem, was dir peinlich ist, gehörst du ...
- Voll.
Ich frage, was dir peinlich ist,
und kann dich einer Gruppe zuordnen.
Z.B. Tattoos - in gewissen Gruppen ist es peinlich,
eines zu haben, in anderen keines zu haben.
- Hast du ein Tattoo?
- Nein. Scham ist auf eine gute Art ...
- Das ist peinlich, was?
- Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Scham ist verräterisch,
es entlarvt unser Selbstideal und Selbstbild.
In der heutigen pluralistischen Gesellschaft
sind die ganz unterschiedlich.
Das ist okay so.
Ich finde es problematisch -
Stichwort Leistungsgesellschaft, Selbstoptimierung -,
wenn man sich dafür schämen muss,
dass man nicht perfekt ist,
dass man nicht gut genug ist.
Das könnte man narzisstische Scham nennen.
Das finde ich aus diversen Gründen problematisch.
Wenn man nicht nur das Falsche anzieht,
sondern man zu wenig Likes erhält,
eine Lücke im Lebenslauf hat -
das ist absurd.
Zu wenig Likes - die Welt der Social Media
ist quasi ein eigenes Kapitel,
wie unglaublich peinlich es ist,
wenn man dort nicht gut performt.
Dies wiederum spiegelt sich im realen Leben wider,
wo alles eine Performanz, ein Performen ist.
Das ist die These
des deutschen Soziologen Andreas Reckwitz.
Wir leben unser Leben nicht mehr,
wir führen es auf.
Alles ist ein Theater,
eine Bühne, auf der man sich zeigen muss.
Ich glaube, das ermüdet uns tatsächlich sehr,
wenn es nur noch darum geht,
zu gefallen, zu performen,
und es peinlich ist,
wenn man nicht vorne dabei ist.
Aber ich würde das Schamgefühl
nicht grundsätzlich verteufeln.
Es ist eine zivilisatorische Errungenschaft,
weil es mit der Reflexivität einhergeht,
dass man sich selbst von aussen betrachten kann
und es einem nicht egal ist, wie man dasteht.
- Einverstanden.
- Weisst du, was mir immer in den Sinn kommt?
- Es ist viel zu viel davon.
- Lass mich den Punkt ausführen.
Das Lied von Mani Matter finde ich noch immer
einer der ganz grossen Beiträge zum Thema Scham:
"Hemmige".
In der letzten Strophe sagt er:
Wenn man sieht, was der Menschheit heute droht,
sieht man nicht nur schwarz, sondern auch rot.
Die Hoffnung besteht allein darin,
dass sie Hemmungen haben.
Das ist der Punkt.
Wir müssen hoffen, dass wir noch Hemmungen
haben, das Schamgefühl nicht ganz verlieren,
dass wir in der Lage sind, uns zu fragen,
was kommende Generationen von uns denken.
Klar, aber wir müssen uns fürs Richtige,
nicht fürs Falsche schämen.
Wenn wir uns für moralische Vergehen schämen -
ich würde es eher berechtigtes Schuldgefühl
oder schlechtes Gewissen nennen -,
dann ist der Fall klar.
Ich beobachte einfach
den Exhibitionismus der Gesellschaft.
Nicht nur in Bezug auf Körper,
sondern auch seelischen Exhibitionismus.
Im Tram wird telefoniert, geweint,
alles Geheimnisse werden verraten,
während ich daneben sitze.
Man fragt sich, ob das okay ist.
Ich finde es okay.
Gewisse Menschen stört das,
aber ich sehe es als Form von Emanzipation,
von Befreiung gegen die Repression,
die Scham sein kann.
Wir kommen noch auf die Frage zurück,
ob Scham gut ist oder nicht.
Bleiben wir bei dieser Szene,
beim Gefühl der Fremdscham.
Das verspüre ich jeweils.
Fremdscham ist ein interessantes Phänomen.
Psychologen und Psychologinnen rätseln, was das ist.
Wenn du Angst hast, kann ich mich in dich einfühlen,
ich sehe dein Gesicht.
Ich kann auf dich eingehen,
doch das heisst nicht, dass ich auch Angst habe.
Bei der Fremdscham hat man das Gefühl,
der anderen Person sei etwas peinlich,
aber ich empfinde Fremdscham.
Es ist mysteriös, wie das genau abläuft.
Ich finde es nicht so mysteriös.
In unserem Gehirn gibt es Spiegelneuronen.
Die sind dafür verantwortlich,
dass wir uns in die anderen hineinversetzen.
Wir sehen eine Aktion - jemand schlägt sich mit dem
Hammer auf die Hand, dann schmerzt uns das auch.
Wir stellen uns vor, wie wir uns dabei fühlen würden.
Dasselbe bei der Scham:
Wie wäre es, wenn mir das passieren würde?
Da kommt dieses Gefühl hoch, man versetzt sich
unwillkürlich in die Handlung, die Aktion des anderen.
Ich glaube, es geht um Tyrannei der Intimität.
Richard Sennet hatte recht.
Es geht nicht darum, dass ich mich fremdschäme.
Ich finde es eine Tyrannei der Intimität,
wenn die Menschen im Tram in ihr Handy weinen
und ihre Eheprobleme besprechen.
Privates wird in den öffentlichen Raum getragen.
Die Menschen spielen nicht mehr ihre Rolle
und bleiben dabei, sondern breiten ihr Intimstes aus.
- Ich finde das unangenehm.
- Warum ist das ihre Rolle?
Vielleicht ist es die neue Rolle.
Nutze Kopfhörer, Ohropax oder schau nicht hin.
Vielleicht gewöhnt man sich daran.
Weshalb ist es dir peinlich?
Weshalb schämst du dich dafür?
Die Gesellschaft entwickelt sich einfach so.
Ich finde es schlimmer,
wenn man sich vor sich selbst für etwas schämen muss.
Wenn man die Zwänge,
die Erwartungen der Gesellschaft so sehr internalisiert,
dass man Schuld- oder Schamgefühle hat.
Aufgrund einer natürlichen Eigenschaft
oder eines Verhaltens, das zum Menschen gehört.
Ich glaube, im Hintergrund
haben wir noch die Vorstellung, die Hoffnung,
wir seien keine Tiere, sondern etwas Besseres,
das ist noch immer eine Kränkung.
Ich sage es mit Nietzsche: Wahre Freiheit besteht wohl darin,
dass man sich nicht mehr vor sich selbst schämen muss.
Auch wenn sich die anderen für mich fremdschämen.
Dass Scham zu einem heimlichen Doppelleben führen kann,
haben wir in "Sternstunde der Nacht" thematisiert,
das seht ihr hier.
Schreibt uns hier unten in die Kommentare,
ob Scham aus eurer Sicht etwas Gutes oder Schlechtes ist.
Und abonniert den Kanal.